[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the ball and throws are pulling fast for
the assist both fans by posting yeah
just follow the basketball this is this
is the new
[Applause]
the portal open throws at Deadwood three
stores mysteriously detain it breaks up
by their to the better cook by DeMar
DeRozan and dome for DeMar DeRozan
well after the service to make the shot
[Applause]
we chose here
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh spectacular
[Applause]
the duck one and one a great job there
for a people bar - Rosie
[Applause]
the Mars cleared for takeoff the sun's
forge ahead again soviet-era 32
[Applause]
and you got the bar to Rosen DeRosa
season over the world
the shot blocker ticking down exactly
knew how much time he had great use of
the dribble
got to keep doing this right now I just
better say
Bouchet here's the tough part Chris
Boucher's going to challenge every shot
challenge everybody that comes in the
panel and this is
what up attaboy Adam left codes you like
that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report